diversity is something that I've always
been in love with because I was when I
was in college I was in English and
classics kind of double major because I
couldn't decide you know which one to go
for and when I heard about comparative
literature my last year at Georgetown I
thought this is perfect it's the study
of different cultures and it's about
putting things together you know so I've
written crazy pieces like comparing
Wallace Stevens to Peter Ark and you
know Dante with Joyce and so on and
that's what I just think is the most
interesting thing is when you juxtapose
two things or three things rather than
focusing on one thing and that's one of
the things the academic world annoyed me
about some times until I discovered
comparative literature and took that
degree at Yale and then ended up
teaching that and I think that the rest
of my life has been an extension of do
working in more than one discipline I
mean in addition to movies I'm very
involved in books I've just finished
another book of my own and I've a
published books because four years ago I
realized that I was having a hard time
after published after selling books to
New York for 20 years or more and having
nearly 20 New York Times bestsellers I
realized that because of all the
conglomeration that was going on among
the publishers perché purchased by large
corporations around the world there was
no longer much chance for a young new
voice to be published what they're
looking for is established brands and
you know the old joke that Stephen King
could publish you know the phone book
with his name on it and that's that's
just the way it is in this you know huge
country where marketing and branding is
what it's all about to get to the
attention of this 300 million audience
so I came up with the idea and what was
happening to me is because I didn't
couldn't publish things as easily as I
could before I published 200
50 books I mean sold them to publishers
and I could take those books to
Hollywood and sell them to Hollywood so
I no longer had books to take to
Hollywood so I decided to start my own
imprint story merchants books which I
did and that was you know five years ago
and we've published over 200 books now
and I now take them to Hollywood and set
them up as series or set them up as
movies and no one seems to mind that
they're not Random House books they
don't even look at the publisher
basically they listen to me pitch the
story at lunch and then they take the
book home and read it and so I've always
been involved in you know it's sort of
like comparative situation because I've
got New York publishing and Hollywood
and I've used them back and forth
against each other one time because
Hollywood has this huge respect for
books and New York has this of movies
primarily because of the marketing money
associated with movies that they can
then write along with when they reach
the book so I'm hoping to have a big
auction coming up soon on a movie that's
appearing this summer after 22 years
called the Meg from Warner Brothers and
it we sold it 22 years ago that's how
long it's been we developed it through
one of my companies and then sold it to
publisher and then we sold it to the
studio and it's been 22 years in
development hell until finally it's it's
getting made and one of the good things
about stories is if they're timeless
well one of my favorite examples of
which is no solace to its author Mel
Herman Melville is that Moby Dick sold
about 60 copies
prior to Melville's death and within two
decades after his death it became not
only an international bestseller but the
great American novel so the stories are
timeless and that's what writers are
capable of doing of creating something
timeless which is an immense value
obviously to the human race the early in
the Odyssey were composed thousands of
years ago and yet they're still on
bookstores shelves you can find them all
over the Internet and so the power of
stories I've always loved the fact that
they were story grows up to be couldn't
be a book or it can strain story grew up
and be a movie I mean once had a
screenplay that I loved that won the
Nichols award one of the highest you
know awards in the business and it it
was placed almost at the top not quite
at the top but I read it loved it tried
to sell it to the studios they all
thought it was too original they didn't
know who the author was and they they
end up passing so I told the author
let's turn this story into a book and so
long story short we did and I sold it to
a major publisher and within a couple of
weeks of selling to a major publisher we
had an auction in Hollywood and sold it
to a major studio and it went into
development and we've done it kind of
the opposite way as somebody was
starting to write a project in one form
and I told him to write it in the other
because of a random conversation I had
with a with an editor and she thought it
was sounded like the best novel she'd
ever heard and he wasn't a novelist but
long story short within three months he
wrote a novel and we sold it and then
sold it for 1.2 million dollars to you
know a major studio in Hollywood so I
thought you know that's my comparative
literature background that the idea of
having two different worlds to put
together and recognize how they're
you're related to each other
I learned that there are wormholes
between New York and LA because when I
was just beginning to shop the the novel
in the second case to New York I send it
to only one publisher which is the
person they told me it wasn't sound like
a great idea she didn't know I only sent
it to her but I sent it to her alone and
three days later I got a call from
George Clooney's partner asking if he
could option it and I said how did you
hear about that he said I can't tell you
and I said well
you know if you can't tell me do you
want to read it I mean what do you want
to do any goes no no we've read it
already and we want to we want to make
an offer on it
so that began an auction for that
property too but I learned that there
was a wormhole going on because I called
the editor and fished around talking to
her and she denied that anyone had ever
read it outside of her office which is
couldn't have been true because clearly
someone had read it
he's got snuck out through the wormhole
so I thought I could only have done this
if I had the whole mentality that I will
not find my niche and only be working in
films I will not only work in books I
want to work in both I love them both
and they're just two different forms of
storytelling and why can't any story
that's dramatic end up in both camps and
that's kind of what I've done throughout
my career is tried to get a story for
both camps it's funny too because I
would think that the entrance into the
literary world the New York literary
world is much more based on you know
pedigree and different you know whereas
Hollywood and you've got a great script
anything goes you're in the front door
if they like it so it sounds like that's
not always the case that sounds like
that's my perception of it it's yeah I
mean that that's a you know without no
offending you it's an old-fashioned
perception okay it's kind of an
all-american old fifties 1950s before
because you can have a great script and
get nowhere in Hollywood it's getting it
to the right person that matters and
even with the great script as that one
was where I talked the guy into writing
in the book and then sold it to you know
in an auction - he had a great script
and and and he was able to get it to
people but they didn't buy it because
they were afraid because what's happened
in the last twenty years is that
Hollywood and New York have become
corporatized they've all been acquired
by international conglomerates you know
there isn't a single studio that isn't
owned by some foreign
you know accumulation with the exception
of Disney which of course is itself
international conglomerate right but
Sony
gilens Columbia and you know paramount
is owned by CBS Viacom you know so
because of that the executives have
totally changed from a world in which
and the same is true in publishing from
a world in which people with guts and
vision made decisions about doing the
story publishing it or greenlight in a
movie now it's it's it's corporate
people wearing suits who are very
worried for their jobs you know whose I
always say their main focus is on their
you know their their gold cards and
their no Mercedes and they don't want to
do anything to jeopardize that whereas
the heads of Studios in the old days
would just take chances this is a great
story I love it I'm gonna I'm gonna do
this story and but now they can't they
have to show marketing reports and this
is true in New York just as well because
fish yet has bought you know the world
warner books and CBS owns Simon &
Schuster and touchstone and all those
things every one of the big companies
hold Springs owns Macmillan and Thomas
Dunne books and tour books and st.
Martin's Press and you know being when
Random House Doubleday right they're all
part of one huge foreign conglomerate
Bertelsmann and so on so because of that
everyone has to think like corporate
employees they have to provide marketing
piell's you know to the editorial
department in the in the marketing
department and the marketing department
has the last say not the editorial
department you know if they go how you
know we're gonna sell 100,000 copies of
this book well I just have a gut feeling
well sorry your track record doesn't
justify your having a gut feeling so
they'll let a really talented brilliant
editor make a couple of decisions like
that a year but if she doesn't prove it
out by those books becoming bestsellers
you know she gets less leash every year
and the same is true in Hollywood and
the studios who
gotten even worse because they their
focus now entirely on brands and in the
last six years or so they are now doing
a fraction of the number of movies they
used to do because they'd rather spend
200 million dollars on a brand or then
take a 50 million dollar chance on a
great story that has no track record
that's why Twilight got kicked out of
paramount because there was sitting
there you know in development hell for
several years then paramount didn't get
it and they didn't understand why it was
gonna be great summit came along and
bought it from Paramount and cashed out
on it and paramount goes okay well they
didn't have any regrets because there's
no they there you know no one sits
around wringing hands that they're all
doing understandable logic and no one
lost their job over it that's the
important part whereas if you greenlight
a movie and it goes down the tubes you
could lose your job you know then you're
you're out shopping for the new Mercedes
you know you're leasing one yeah yeah
and another in place so that's kind of
what's happened to a world but in the
meantime this the need for stories
continues and storytellers are still
hugely in demand you just have to find a
new path each time that's how I started
you know the imprint so I can get around
that issue and now I just take new to
new york big brands like something with
the word kennedy on it or the word
dracula i can sell those still but i
don't i just i know i can't sell smaller
books i'll try sometimes because i love
the book so much but it variably comes
down to better publish this ourselves
you